[Aplausos]
parece el robo es la consigna que se
mueve de costa a costa entre los
partidarios del presidente donald trump
las protestas en apoyo al mandatario
incrementaron cuando el conteo de los
votos en el estado de pensilvania le dio
a job aiden la victoria de estas
elecciones presidenciales
vimos un intento de golpe de estado en
nuestro país nos están quitando la
libertad y nos está quitando la gente
que no le gusta eeuu y están
atrincherados en lo que se llama el
estado profundo
arizona carolina del norte y georgia las
protestas se concentran principalmente
en los estados en los que hasta este
sábado seguía el conteo de los votos
alentados por el presidente trump sus
seguidores cuestionan sin fundamentos la
integridad del proceso electoral y se
niegan a aceptar la victoria
si no se revierte si no cambiamos el
conteo y si este no es legítimo
bardem será nuestro próximo presidente
de ezker bien expresó desafortunadamente
creo que eso va a llevar a nuestro país
al borde del precipicio
hasta el momento no se han reportado
hechos de violencia pero se vive una
atmósfera tensa los funcionarios
electorales en varios estados donde
bardem derrotó a trump dijeron sentirse
intimidados por parte de los
manifestantes temen que las protestas se
incrementen en los próximos días si el
presidente se sigue llegando a aceptar
el resultado